When it comes to science, we think there’s
a saying that is fairly applicable, “who
dares, wins”.
Fans of military history may recognise that
as the motto of the Special Air Services (SAS).
However, we feel scientists and researchers
deserve to use it just as much, because sometimes
they take risks too.
Just ask Nobel Prize winner Barry J. Marshall
if you don’t believe us.
Marshall is known primarily for his work revolving
around peptic ulcers.
If you don’t think that sounds important,
ask someone who has had them how painful they
are and then shield your groin from the barrage
of kicks as they try to give you some idea
of the crippling level of pain.
Beyond the agony and the decreased quality
of life it can cause, peptic ulcers have been
linked to increased chances of one getting
stomach cancer.
Prior to Marshall’s work, it was commonly
accepted by the medical community that ulcers
were caused by a combination of stress, spicy
food and too much stomach acid being produced.
Something that many people still believe to
this day.
Seriously, ask anyone on the street what causes
stomach ulcers and “stress” will likely
be one of the answers you’ll get.
Marshall’s first significant encounter with
stomach ulcers was while training to become
a specialist in gastroenterology.
During this time, he came into contact with
Dr Robin Warren, who just so happened to be
treating several patients with crippling stomach
ulcers.
During treatment, Warren had collected samples
of a bacteria that seemed present in every
ulcer patient.
This bacteria, Helicobacter pylori was later
found to be directly responsible for ulcers.
That said, neither Warren nor Marshall discovered
the bacteria.
In his work, Helicobacter pylori: Physiology
and Genetics, Marshall himself penned a section
on how humanity has been aware of the bacteria
since 1893.
Along with this, links between the bacteria
and ulcers had been suggested as early as
1940 by Dr. A. Stone Freedberg, a cardiologist
from Harvard.
In fact, it’s widely accepted that if Freedberg
would have continued with his research into
these microbes and ulcers, he likely would
have solved the problem decades before Marshall
did.
However, Freedberg’s boss pressured him
to abandon his research in favor of something
that would be easier to prove, so that’s
exactly what he did.
In the meantime, millions of people suffered
and lost chunks of their stomachs via wholly
unnecessary surgery.
One of the reasons Freedberg, and indeed just
about every other scientist and microbiologist
that wasn’t a crazed Australian, gave up
on this line of reasoning was due to overwhelming
opposition from the wider scientific community.
As mentioned, up until Marshall shotgunned
a glass of the bacteria, the commonly accepted
cause of ulcers was stress and stomach acid,
as it was believed no bacteria could thrive
in the highly acidic environment of the stomach.
You know, even though people had been finding
said bacteria in stomachs since 1893.
There was also the fact that there was a lot
of documented evidence that antibiotics cleared
ulcers right up.
In the case of Freedberg, when he made his
prediction about the link between bacteria
and ulcers and tests were inconclusive, his
superiors essentially told him to give up
and stop wasting his time.
On a similar vein, when Greek doctor John
Lykoudis presented his findings that antibiotics
eradicated ulcers in 1964, his evidence was
largely ignored because it went against the
current consensus.
In fact, in 1968, when Lykoudis refused to
stop treating (and curing) his patients’
stomach ulcers with antibiotics, he was fined
4000 Drachma for his troubles and was largely
regarded as a quack until Marshall went freshman
on a glass of Helicobacter pylori.
In other words, suggesting ulcers were caused
by anything other than stress was career suicide.
Regardless, both Marshall and Warren continued
with their research and although the pair
managed to cultivate Helicobacter pylori,
they couldn’t make
it cause stomach ulcers, regardless of how
many piglets they injected it into.
As Marshall stated,
“…1984 was a difficult year.
I was unsuccessfully attempting to infect
an animal model.
There was interest and support from a few
but most of my work was rejected for publication
and even accepted papers were significantly
delayed.
I was met with constant criticism that my
conclusions were premature and not well supported.
When the work was presented, my results were
disputed and disbelieved, not on the basis
of science but because they simply could not
be true.
It was often said that no one was able to
replicate my results.
This was untrue but became part of the folklore
of the period.
I was told that the bacteria were either contaminants
or harmless commensals.
At the same time I was successfully experimentally
treating patients who had suffered with life
threatening ulcer disease for years.
Some of my patients had postponed surgery
which became unnecessary after a simple 2
week course of antibiotics and bismuth.
I had developed my hypothesis that these bacteria
were the cause of peptic ulcers and a significant
risk for stomach cancer.
If I was right, then treatment for ulcer disease
would be revolutionized.
It would be simple, cheap and it would be
a cure.
It seemed to me that for the sake of patients
this research had to be fast tracked.
The sense of urgency and frustration with
the medical community was partly due to my
disposition and age.
However, the primary reason was a practical
one.
I was driven to get this theory proven quickly
to provide curative treatment for the millions
of people suffering with ulcers around the
world.”
He finally reasoned that there had to be an
easier way.
Even though Marshall was absolutely convinced
the bacteria caused stomach ulcers, he couldn’t
test his theory on humans.
However, no law could stop Marshall from testing
his theory on himself.
Which is exactly what he did on June 12, 1984.
Marshall finished his workday after drinking
the bacteria.
If movies have taught me anything, scientists
who test their theories on themselves invariably
become either superheroes or supervillains,
and that’s kind of what happened here.
At least, I assume most people who’ve had
the misfortune of suffering from ulcers consider
Mashall to be something of a superhero.
So what exactly happened after he drank the
offending microbes?
Despite Marshall thinking that it would take
weeks if not months for anything significant
to occur, just a few days later, he developed
ulcers for the first time in his life, along
with presumably the inability to stop extending
his middle finger at the medical community.
Marshall put a stop to his little experiment
after two weeks when his wife found out about
it.
He didn’t need to be a scientist to know
that upsetting your wife is worse for one’s
well-being than stomach ulcers, even when
factoring in the potential increased risk
of getting stomach cancer.
But, as he said, “She was already convinced
about the risk of these bacteria and I knew
I would never get her approval.
This was one of those occasions when it would
be easier to get forgiveness than permission.”
After a biopsy to further document this event,
he then treated himself with antibiotics and
was soon fully cured of the ulcers.
At this point, certain people within the medical
community started paying closer attention
to Marshall’s research and taking it a whole
lot more seriously.
However, it still took time and a significant
amount of work and publicity to get the message
across; even into the early 1990s after curing
numerous people of ulcers and publishing several
papers on the subject, many in the medical
field still scoffed at him and even outright
accused him of pushing snake oil-like treatments
onto their patients through the media who
was eating up the battle Marshall was waging.
Of course, the fact that these patients predominately
ended up cured was winning over more and more
medical professionals as time went by.
Finally, in 1994, it all changed when the
National Institutes of Health (NIH) held a
two day summit in Washington D.C. over the
matter.
They could no longer ignore the evidence.
At the end of the summit, they released a
statement stating that “the key to treatment
of duodenal and gastric ulcer was detection
and eradication of Helicobacter pylori.”
With that stamp of approval on his work, the
majority of the holdouts in the medical community
switched their stance and accepted Marshall’s
hypothesis.
Eleven years later, in 2005, he was given
a Nobel prize for his work, which was all
the more impressive given the extreme opposition
he had faced.
Sure, scientists (and really everyone) should
always question new ideas and thoroughly vet
them.
But when a mountain of well documented evidence
in easily repeatable scientifically performed
experiments clearly shows the old theory was
wrong and the new one right, one shouldn’t
continue to oppose it just because it’s
not what was believed before.
Yet, it took Marshall climbing on top of that
mountain of evidence and showing his ulcer
filled stomach before anyone started to listen.
Let that be a lesson to everyone.
Even the smartest of us humans are amazingly
susceptible to getting stuck in a “knowledge
rut.”
Always question everything, and never stop
learning.
Bonus Fact:
• Funny enough, the first “news” agency
to report on Marshall’s little experiment
was Star newspaper, which as he put it was
“a tabloid that often features stories about
alien babies being adopted by Nancy Reagan.
This was right up their alley.
The next day the story appeared, ‘Guinea-pig
doctor discovers new cure for ulcers … and
the cause.’”
Needless to say, this wasn’t an auspicious
beginning to being taken seriously, but certain
key people did take notice thanks to the story,
and funding for further experiments started
to trickle in.
I’m not sure what’s more interesting about
this fact, that such a tabloid actually broke
a major world news story or the revelation
that they actually do real reporting sometimes
rather than just sitting around making stuff
up.